I am NOT a medical doctor I'm a musician
I'm about to embark on a concert to work
in the deep south
what other experience do you have public
relations you've listened to the
criticism about this movie that has been
a fantastic story and you guys have done
a good job I think of explaining that
people are getting it twisted I think we
live in a very reactive time you know
something happens and before you hear
all the details we're all jumping on the
bandwagon in some way or other so I
that's about all I can say is we have to
always take a moment and pause and get
the facts before we react when did you
know this was a special movie when I
read the sprits I didn't know dr.
Shirley or dr. Shirley story so I felt
compelled to be a part of telling it so
that other young people could understand
what what choices he made so that we
could you know know his legacy and
understand his legacy
the nice thing how important is it to be
here tonight Regina King is a queen and
it's her first of many I'm sure Oscar
nominations and to be here to celebrate
her and to celebrate all these beautiful
women it's important to me can you buy
some booze for my friends and I not
interested please
hey oh there's my girl
this never happened okay thanks again
for doing this ma'am
you guys want a party like rock stars
follow me
well I just play a very damaged woman
who does some very damaging things to
some teenagers the trailer is out it's
crazy and it's it's beyond nuts I love
it Wow where'd you get that from where'd
you where'd you go together you know I
think these types of roles aren't really
offered to us so when my friend found it
and the part was written for a white
woman and it still is I just slid in
there and I wanted to try something new
and so I'm grateful to tape for
introducing me to mom
but people don't know that ma is not
she's not being called ma cuz she's
taking care of these kids ma is a term
of endearment I didn't know I would see
mom and Auntie and all this stuff on my
Instagram and I'm like do I know these
kids what does this mean so I'm learning
something new too
[Music]
[Applause]
you